the approach road to the controversial
Berlin Brandenburg Airport is as empty
as the sprawling grounds opening dates
have come and gone but construction
continues and still there is not a plane
in sight at a crisis meeting Airport CEO
Hartmut made ORN cuts to the chase that
in does all kinds often
I'm going to be very open here and tell
you that every day here at the airport
brings new surprises each day something
different happens and if everything went
according to plan it would be a first we
should assume here there will be further
internal changes and that the opening
date could be pushed back again there
have been a series of missteps planning
and construction in separate hands
changes in management and untested
technology the main problem the fire
alarm system is still not functioning
although the airport is still a work in
progress a number of people including
these dentists have already set up shop
on the ground
Ettore Caminiti was less efficient with
how it was going to take years to open
we welcomed the first postponement which
was for six months because we were very
stressed when the second one was
announced we started to wonder whether
there might also be a third or a fourth
one but then we decided to go ahead with
our plan so now we have to live with the
consequences of that decision now the
talk is of 2016 yeah that's the best
I've heard so far
hope yeah what's your guess
good love I live in all we always expect
the worst and so far that served us well
if the mother would go fine they
invested more than six hundred thousand
euros in their Airport dental surgery
but so far only two of their four
treatment rooms pay for themselves if
the front I'm talking me things are
picking up by the day as more and more
workers turn up here you kind of wonder
where they all come from but then again
this is a huge place with this get in
20 forget this job I know all the
important groups are already here
there's the fire service customs federal
border guards
they'll all just be put into action when
the airport really starts operating on
Seabiscuit Mindy parfait is Franz Joseph
slavka is an independent construction
expert with plenty of experience of
large building projects he regards the
constant postponement of the opening
date as absurd yes but that once we had
Cynthia wantoniy Medina invest Ian I
feel sorry for those who invested in it
and now I have to sit around and wait
for something to happen something that
isn't happening that's octene geek
what's going on here is political game
playing and I consider that to be
particularly objectionable politically
speaking she loved me a lot before this
guy it shows a complete disregard for
the taxpayer this would destroy us all
ryoga's Philly goes off list each month
of delay costs millions of euros and the
public is fed up of being strung along
by the airport CEO but he appears
unfazed let me say this I was brought on
board to make sure the airport is
finished my role is that of the driver
to push it forwards and that comes under
the motto what can be finished will be
finished as quickly as possible until
such time costs continue to mount and
the opening date remains a distant dream
you